by the end of this year we can replace
100 bcm of gas imports from russia
that is two-thirds of what we import
from them
this will end our over dependency and
give us much needed room to maneuver
two-thirds by the end of this year
it's hard
bloody hard but it's possible if we're
willing to go further and faster than
we've done before
with the plan we outlined today the eu
can end its dependence on russian gas
and re-power europe
fit455 once implemented will reduce the
eu's total gas consumption by 20 by
sorry by 30
by 2030.
that is
100 billion cubic meters of gas we will
no longer need just to underscore that
i'm not here we're not standing here
cadre and myself to say this is going to
be in any way easy
but i am also deeply convinced that even
if it's not easy even if it's going to
be very hard it is something we need to
do because now it's also intimately
linked to our security
i'll need to move beyond dependence on
russian oil and gas uh as we
as we go forward and even though it's
incredibly difficult for some european
countries including colleagues of the
visagraph 4 today
everybody can see that we now need to to
do that
and then there was an agreement also on
the need to to show the people of
ukraine now that whatever happens uh
once a free sovereign independent
ukraine is protected and restored we
will rebuild and we will have a plan a
marshall plan to rebuild ukraine